Зеленський нещодавно під час спілкування
зі студентами та викладачами довідник
закладів вищої освіти Австралії
підкреслили українців сьогодні мотивує
кожна перемога тому ми вболіваємо за
наших спортсменів артистів та науковців
як ніколи
пригадую як під час відкриття
європейських університетських ігор
організатори забезпечили вихід нашої
команди під пісню Добрий вечір ми з
України а весь зал зустрічав наш стоячи
і оплесками потім наше спортсмени
розказували як в цей момент вони
відчували значне емоційне піднесення і
гордість за нашу державу вдячність
усьому прогресивному людству за
підтримку України у війні проти Росії у
багатьох студентів Катились сльози
колись з прапором України вони стояли
наприділі Під звуки
нашої держави
від імені спортивний студентської спілки
України адресує слова щирої вдячності
кожному студенту який доклав
максимальних зусиль для демонстрації
високих спортивних досягнень велика шана
нашим тренерам які підготували до
супроводжували успіхи наших спортсменів
прошу шановному міністра освіти і науки
України шкодуйте Сергія Миколайовича
принять вдячні спілки за підтримку та
допомогу у розвитку студентського спорту
та гідного репрезентацію України на
міжнародний спортивний рівень
користуючись нагодою хочу подякувати
фісу та європейська асоціації
університетського спорту За надання
організаційної та фінансової допомоги
для участі України у вказаних змаганнях
найкращі слова вдячності президента в
національних спортивних Федерації за
підтримку наших ініціатив особливо
присутнім народному депутату України
президента всеукраїнської футбольної
асоціації студентів дулько Іван Іванович
та заступнику керівника офісу президента
України президента Федерації бадмінтону
України Дніпро Олексію сергійовичу
»
за останні 5 років не дивлячись на
тривалу пандемію війну з російськими
терористами Нам вдалося на законодавчому
рівні закріпити повноваження спілки два
роки тому внесено в відповідні зміни до
Закону України Про фізичну культуру і
спорту як активізувати роботу
підрозділів на місцях та у закладах
вищої освіти за початкувати них низьку
масових заходів відзначення Міжнародного
дня студентського спорту проведення
студентської Мілі різноманітних
флешмобів Challenger Ігор тощо
забезпечити гідне представництво України
на рівні фісу та Європейської Асоціації
це результат роботи всієї команди
спортивної студентської спілки України у
співпраці з комітетом фізичного
виховання і спорту Міністерства освіти і
науки України голова комітету та
генеральний секретар спілки Стеценка
Вадим Григорович
а також з усім ректорським корпусом
Спасибі за взаємодію президенту спілки
ліхтарів закладів вищої освіти України
електро Київського національного
університету будівництва архітектури
кулікову підтримкусію які очолює і
Київський міський підрозділ спортивної
студентської спілки України великі
внесок у здобутки вітчизняного
студентського спорту роблять члени
виконавчого комітету спілки та керівники
територіальних підрозділів
електровідвідних закладів вищої освіти
зокрема голова наглядової влади спілки
президент Української федерації
учнівського спорту гребада ман
Володимирович
торговельно-економічного університету
мазадакія Анатолій Антонович почесний
електро Сумського державного
університету Василів Анатолій Васильович
ректор Львівського державного
університету фізичної культури імені
Івана бобинського приступає Винник Олег
Прикарпатського національного
університету імені Василя Стефаника
цепенда Ігореві білки
електронаціонального університету
Полтавська політехніка імені Юрія
Кондратюка онищенка Володимира
Олександрович ректор західноукраїнського
національного університету рисувати
Андрій
та інші Дорогі колеги кожному із вас Я
безмежно вдячний що в цей накладний час
ви робите все можливе а часом і
неможливо для розвитку студентського
спорту На завершення Дозвольте висловити
впевненість Що Ми і надалі разом будемо
турбуватися про студентів спортсменів
створення для
сприятливих умов Для успішного поєднання
здобуття освітньої кваліфікації та
підготовки її участі у змаганнях
міжнародного рівня найближчі з них - це
університетські Кубок світу фісу комбатс
з єдиноборства у Турції та зимову
всесвітній Університетський
університетські ігри фісу».»
шановні учасники європейських
університетів Києва
встановлені європейських студентів
європейських студентів роботи які
відбудуться які відбудуться які
відбудуться які відводиться Які
відвозиться Які відвозиться Які
відвозиться
які відвозиться які відбудуться які
відбулися
[музика]
[оплески]
Слава Україні
надзвичай
обладнання
[музика]
Прикарпатського національного університе
[оплески]
ту
порушується подяка Міністерства
чемпіонату України
народного депута
[оплески]
України третього національного
університету
[оплески]
оголошується Адміністрація Президента
забезпечення політичного розвитку
студентів на Європейських
університету в Україні директора
західноукраїнського національного
університету Святого Миколая
політичного розвитку конкурентів
європейського спорту в Україні з першого
за
Ступниця
[оплески]
подяка адміністра
забезпечення політи
чного на Європейських
організаційної війни
[оплески]
Європейської Асоціації
Незалежності
всі Всі розуміють
Україною
спортовим делегація з України могла вже
одягах
очевищайте з добитими дали А тих медалей
і студентів
швидше місце в класифікації
ви здобитих медалей зважена але видає
місце вже ні То єсть найважливіше
ходжу Я аудио студентам з України в рік
вже
ми йшли вже найважневіша історія
час разом і вже був то вираз так і от
Джиммі й Солідарності
до України як і декларації України вже
це разом з нами в європейських
спільнокоче Бич і компаніям зато вже
Україна тих європейських
вартощів богатирських журналів
українських дуже в тих філісом на фронті
Я з Євгенієм розмовляю мені каждый
робить То це може жили Україна могла
быть краєм волным самодельним і
незалежним от впливу
А Тарас Так же не звикли ні безпечне до
сумчата
Україні сердечні жінки і жити добре
до виступу запрошується почесний
президент спортивної студентської спілки
України Президент Національної академії
під Наук України Кремінь Василь
Григорович
Сергій Миколайовичу
А я включив
Шановні колеги я хотів би продовжити
думки висловлені тут особливо
Сергій Миколайовичем шкарликом Я вже
учасник активний універсіат і
Європейський студентських Ігор з 1999
року з року коли
відбулась універсальна
пальма-де-мальорка Коли наш нинішній
міністр спорту сім'ї молоді стало
чемпіоном цієї університети
І я хотів би сказати що завжди Україна
достойна виступала на
всесвітніх на Європейських змаганнях і
було багато медалей але думаю ніколи не
було таких хвилюючих Ігор як в цьому
році в Лодзі у Польщі
вперше українським спортсменам довелося
виступати в умовах війни
війни яка Ну буквально нав'язана
агресором Росії Яка абсолютно нічим не
обґрунтована нічим об'єктивно не
покликана але війна коли
тисячі і тисячі наших молодих людей
захищають Багато з них гинуть багато
поранені і в цих умовах безумовно виїзд
в команди найбільш масової команди на
європейські ігри це вже сам по собі
подвиги я щиро вдячний як представник
ветеранського вже року Сергій
Миколайович Іван і всьому міністерству і
безумовно офісу президента у Верховній
Раді спілці пана Євгенівна комітетом
фізкультури і спорту Міністерства
Петрусь і всім ректорам
нашої країни за те що сталося можливим
друге що я хотів би сказати це безумовно
та обставина що ось ці ігри показали що
не тільки відносно благополучні
університети сьогодні Львів
тернопіль-київ івано-франківськ десь
Полтава беруть активну участь ви
подивіться як Здорово представлений
Харківський університет
причому не тільки з огляду кількості
учасників але й результатів боротьби Я
думаю що окрім всього ось тут цими
студентами харківські керував керувались
вони і ну бажанням показати свою мідь
свою готовність відстоювати не тільки
результати спортивному полі а і Україну
у боротьбі на на на фронті тому щира
вдячні всім студентам спортсменам
присутнім тут відсутнім тут за те що
вони ось в таких умовах змогли себе
достать достойним чином проявити Ну і
безумовно Я думаю що ми повинні
подякувати європейську спортивну
структуру нашого польського друга якого
я років 30 уже знаю за те що вони
допомогли нам взяти участь у цих
змаганнях створили всі необхідні умови
для того щоб наші студенти виступили
достойна
Шановні колеги я радий що традиції
студентського спорту в Україні
нарощується постійно позитивно
позитивний розвиток відбувається і
переконаний це Що це ще одне
вологі волевиявлення українського народу
української молоді
в боротьбі за свою національну
ідентичність за цілісність України за її
суверенітет тому Слава Україні і Героям
слава в тому числі Героям які сидять тут
студентам
[оплески]
Шановні колеги Шановні студенти Давайте
я як представник засновника трошки ми
поламаємо це все Бо дітям більше сидіти
на самій запасних же нудно вам я так
розумію ми дамо ще як кажуть там два-три
слова і все і розходимося кожен по своїм
справам і йдем хто до журналістів хто
святкувать хто поспілкуватися в кого
фото там все інше я хотів запросити до
слова нашого Великого товариша колегу
всіх нас Олексій Сергійовича Дніпро
вулиця цій запрошую вас дуже дякую
шановне Сергію Миколайовичу шановний
друзі колеги ви на Вікторові що я
звичайно Ну я дуже коротко але хочу
звичайно приєднатися до вітань вітань
нашій студентської спортивної спілці за
тріумфальної такий результат в історії
спілки в історії України друге місце на
Європейських студентських спортивних
іграх Це дійсно історичний результат і
це звичайно результат а-а дуже важкої
роботи не лише спілки а і Міністерство
освіти і науки е-е вищих навчальних
закладів які з усіх умовах змогли е-е
підготувати команди і змогли їх вивести
супроводжувати забезпечувати і так далі
І так далі і хотів би додати до слів
Василя Григорію що а те щодо вищих
навчальних закладів не лише західного
регіону Якщо говорити про мою рідну
федерацію бадмінтона ми були
представлені двома вищі навчальні
закладами це Харківський політехнічним
університетом і
миколаївським університетом
кораблебудування імені Макарова це Якраз
ті університети які міста які ви знаєте
постраждали і страждають і в яких умовах
перебувають Але тим не менше
представники цих університетів
представників цих міст довели і в
Україні всій Європі про свій характер
свою волю до перемоги і звичайно що це
така їхня перемога їхні медалі вони
звичайно вони такі потрошку лягають в
загальному скарбничку великої нашої
перемоги над
цим злом
Я хотів би дуже подякувати Європейському
студентському спортивного спілці за
рішення про відсторонення російських і
білоруських спортсменів від змагань
оскільки а-а
позиція і керівництво держави і
керівництва Федерації вона жорстка і
незмінна в Україні що тези про те що
спорту запали політикою це тези для
ток-шоу для
запорізькам А хто був вчасно підтримують
війну і Ми вчасно підтримують вбивство в
тому числі спортсменів і атлетів А той
не може виступати на будь-яких
міжнародних змагань тому я хотів би щиро
подякувати за це і
знаючи які сили докладають от якраз за
поребриком до повернення цих до змагань
прошу надалі триматися і триматися цьому
рішенні до перемоги цивілізованого світу
над цим злом тому ще раз хотів дуже
подякувати хотів привітати наших героїв
наших студентів спортсменів Ну і ми
надалі
завіряє вас Будемо докладати всіх зусиль
для максимального сприяння у розвитку
студентського спорту в Україні Дякую
дуже
Дякую вам але правда коли дорослі
дорослі дяді говорять там все треба щось
і молоді здавати казати давайте двох
наших капітанів запросим до слова
Вероніку Космач та Андрія мельника я
думаю що ви точно знаєте ті емоції які
переповнювали вас коли ви виходили на на
цій майданчики спортивні і здобули такі
Перемоги запрошуємо вас
всім добрий вечір Я хочу сказати є
багато говорити не буду всі так багато
чого сказали і просто всі знають які
зараз тяжкий час для нас всіх і хочеться
в першу чергу подякувати всім хто
прийняв тому що всі спортсмени поїхали
на ці змагання і змогли їду представити
нашу країну кожен спортсмен Я вважаю що
це герой
дейк десь по своєму але герой вони в
такий час складний змогли зібрати силами
тренера змогли зібрати спортсменів
і щоб ми виборювали медалі і їду
представляли нашу країну всі знаємо як
нам було там складно ми грали у нас
кожного було свої ігри якісь
змагання ми читали потім новини на все
засмучували ми переживали Але все одно
всі зібралися ми як гідно представили
нашу країну вибрали дуже багато медалей
дуже Всім дякую
[оплески]
Доброго дня
я як гравець студентської команди
вміння футболу
дуже вдячний всім хто нас підтримував то
за нас вболівав
Дякую моїй команді
як Дякуємо моїй команді завдяки їм Я
получив від знаку найкращого гравця
студентської чи Чемпіонату світу
Вибачте не готувався
Дякую тренерам за короткий час вони
змогли з нашого складу зробити більш ніж
достатньо щоб посісти друге місце
такої команди як Бразилія в фіналі грати
і було дуже важко Ну на мій погляд ми
зробили все щоб
зайняти перше місце Ну трошки Нам не
хватило
Бразилія не пропустила ні одного голову
від другої команди тільки ми змогли їм
забивати голи
Слава Україні не готувався вибачте
Дякую Вероніка Дякую Андрію
Мені приємно запросити до слова не
просто народного депутата а
людину яка багато вклала в студентський
футбол в українській футбол
це вже зобов’яза
Дякую шановні Сергій Миколайович Дорогі
колеги студенти Мені приємно брати
участь в сьогоднішньому заході і завжди
от тут шановні товариство говорило
правильні красиві слова завжди приємно
звітувати коли я за що Бо насправді
Україна сьогодні дуже потребує Перемоги
і Перемоги на кожному фронті спортивному
науковому на фронті бойових дій вони
додаються у всій країні мотивують усіх і
надихають вірою в те що ми переможемо Ми
переможемо цього ворога агресора і
повернемося до звичного життя а зараз
кожен на своєму місці там де може такі
важливі Перемоги здобуває і яку є мені
було дуже приємно спостерігати Як
борються наші студенти наскільки вони
викладаються
як Вони переживають за свою країну і як
гідної представляють це другого Кошти
я хотів би сказати що коли
ми дивилися вся країна мала можливість
на каналі Xsport спостерігати чемпіонат
світу з футзалу серед студентів це дуже
важливо що всеукраїнський канал
транслювався змагання коли нас в фіналі
де мало хто вірив що бразильців можна
щось продемонструвати враховуючи їхню
попередні ігри від золотих медалей
відділили дві хвилини тому що за дві
хвилини до завершення матчу ми
перемагали 4:3
і тільки те що вони змогли розіграти
5-го гравця дало можливість бразильцям
зрівняти а потім повертаємо здобути
перемогу Але
ту гру яку показали Наша команда вона
була гра переможця Так що я хочу
подякувати хлопцям за такий крутий
безумовно дуже сильний виступ Те саме
стосується європейських ігор
дивилися ми в Ютубі всі ці ігри і наших
дівчат тут заліз так футболістів і
хлопців футболістів і футболістів і це
дійсно брало гордість за те що ми можемо
показати що Україна є сильною спортивною
студентською і дуже такою знаєте коли
один за одного вболіває коли на трибунах
звучало Слава Україні а це були наше
вболівальники здебільшого студента які
також представляли інші види спорту але
вони приходили підтримати інших Це
важливо коли я такий спільний кулак Але
найголовніше тут це
безумовно те що в таких складних умовах
держава спромоглася відрядити команди
безумовно нам допомогли нашим міжнародні
партнери але збори провести відрядити
команди Це дуже важливо тому Сергій
Миколайович ми вдячні за те що ви як
міністр
пробиваєте ці речі підтримуєте
безумовно Євгеній Вікторович вам
величезна вдячність як не тільки ректору
але президенту
спортивної студентської спілки тому що
це от напор з яким потрібно
здобувати можливості для того щоб
студенти могли виступати він дуже-дуже
важливо Я вдячний всім студентам це
перемога ваша але це перемога всієї
України Я хочу вам поаплодувати за те що
ви дійсно зробили для нас це велике
свято для всієї України для того
і слава Україні
Дякую вам адже
швидко завершуємо У нас є ще два
представника наших відокремлених
підрозділів спортивних студентів
запрошуємо вас до слова
Шановний Сергій Миколайовичу шановний
Олексію сергійовичу шановні студенти
спортсмени Шановні колеги друзі
Дозвольте її Веди мені студентів які
представляли полтавську політехніку на
цих змаганнях щиро подякувати Сергій
Миколайовичу за ту довіру яку висловили
до наших студентів Адже для студентів
Полтавської політехніки Це був дебют
дебют виступати у складі збірної України
і цей дебют до вінчався першим і другим
місцем з такого силового виду спорту як
карате тому безумовно ми Гордій і
радість того що і наші студенти зробили
так щоб гімн України лунав на
Європейських студентських іграх і це
відчуття таке гордості гордості за
перемогу наших студентів і це вселяє
віру і впевненість в Перемоги України
над ворогом Я ще раз дякую бажаю
подальших успіхів подальших здобусків
поддобутків і подальших перемог нашим
студентів студентам і нашій країні Слава
Україні Героям слава дякую вам
і запросимо до слова мого колегу нашого
товариша без змінного такого прихильника
спорту студентського спорту Андрій
і закону єдиний непохитний а життя
безжалісно просте має право жити тільки
сильний тільки сильний переможе все сила
наших збройних сил
показує що Україна переможе
а наша сила ваша сила друга студента
ваше завзяття показали наскільки сильний
наш фронт і наскільки ми можемо
перемагати на спортивніх Я схиляю голову
перед вами що в такій непростий Я схиляю
голову перед вашими батьками що вони вас
відпустили я схиляє голови перед вашими
тренерами які зуміли мобілізувати ці
сили і вдячний нашому міністерству особі
Сергій Миколайович Я вдячний офісу
президента особливо цієї Сергійович Я
вдячний кожному своєму колезі за те що
ми зуміли об'єднатися і показали що якщо
ми об'єднаємося ми переможемо це приклад
для своєї України це приклад для нашого
депутатського корпусу це приклад для
всіх політичних сил Ми повинні бути
єдині як єдиними були в лодці і як єдине
зараз європейське співтовариство яке
виключило саме
спортсменів і представників Росії і
Білорусії як країна-агресора і ми
показали що якщо ми єднаємось то ми
перемагаємо до нових перемог Слава
Україні Слава нації
Шановні колеги давайте ще раз всі
подякуємо поаплодуємо нашим студентам
тренерам переможцям всім учасникам
Ще раз ще раз висловив вдячність і
подякуватиму ручку який без
безпрецедентно підтримував і українську
збірну і і взагалі держава Україна який
був неодноразово в Україні який
спілкувався з нами і при цьому важкі
часи як і весь польський народ не
відвернувся дякую а давай
вам до нових перемог Слава Україні